we're joined by head and out now
spokesperson for the State Department
who can bring some clarity to these
questions that are being asked had a
thank you for joining us thank you why
didn't the US and its allies wait for
the OPCW to get into Syria and carry out
its investigations yeah well we when we
look at the OPCW their role is to get in
there and determine exactly what
substance was used that is their only
role in doing that and they are really
the gold standard there is something
called the joint investigative mechanism
which is the one that then assigns
responsibility who use that chemical
substance the joint investigative
mechanism is no longer in the works
right now and that's because Russia
essentially killed it at the United
Nations so the reason that the u.s. to
get to get to your question the reason
that the US and its allies decided to
act is that we all have our own
intelligence information that leads us
to believe conclusively that Syria acted
and that Syria acted with chemical
weapons against its own people so we
have our own information OPCW has its
own information as well so just on that
could you to the extent that you are
able just clarify what evidence did you
have that it was Assad to blame for this
attack and that chlorine and potentially
sarin was used well some of this is
intelligence information that we just
can't disclose at this time because it's
still classified but I can tell you we
have a plenty of evidence that points to
Bashar al-assad for example there are
other regime elements and other entities
that some would like to try to blame
like Russia would like to try to blame
do not have helicopters that can drop
barrel bombs so we know Bashar al-assad
has these helicopters dropping barrel
bombs we know that he has chemical
weapons Russia was supposed to help
Syria get rid of its chemical weapons
back in 2014 or so Russia failed to do
that Russia failed to help Bashar
al-assad get rid of those chemical
weapons and that's why you're we are
seeing a continuation of attacks today
how confident were you though but
chlorine and potentially sarin had been
used were you certain again we have lots
and lots of evidence pointing to both
chlorine and sarin we have that
information available to the US
government the US has some information
Russia
excuse me France and and the UK have
information as well so we acted together
as allies recognizing that we're not
wanting to have to do this
Bashar al-assad for far too long has
killed innocent men women and children
and it's our responsibility as the
international community to act Russia
has failed to do so Iran continues to
cause destabilizing activities in Syria
and then Syria of course continues to
kill its own people so we came together
and said to the world that we have to
act and we have to stop this there have
been some concerns that perhaps the US
and its allies of course violated the UN
Charter in the absence of UN Security
Council resolution and a self-defense
justification in authorizing the use of
force in Syria what justification under
international law do you believe the US
and its allies have intervening in Syria
in this case you know with those claims
the claims that you just mentioned are
completely bogus and that's something
that Russia tries to do to take the
attention away from what really happened
we have a responsibility as a world to
attack and stop what Syria is doing and
so the United States with her allies
went after three sites these are
pinprick targets three targeted sites
that we know were housing and testing
chemical weapons that is something that
is a we were responsible in doing so it
was the right thing to do so we look
forward to more members of the
international community continuing to
support what we did we have heard a
chorus of support from many other
countries around the world who support
what we have done I would find it hard
to imagine that people have a difficult
time with our decision to go after these
chemical weapons programs at these three
facilities
the only one who would do so would be
Russia and Syria there is of course a
clear moral case for intervention and I
don't disagree with you but what I'm
asking about is what you believe is the
basis under international law for
intervention Downing Street issued a
legal document talking about the
exception allowed to it under
humanitarian relief what is it that the
u.s. believes on that well look the
United States hasn't it has authority
under article 2 of our Constitution for
the President to act in the best
interests of the United States and in
the interests of our US forces so United
States did that under that and that is
what we support look I'm not an expert
in international law I'm not gonna say
that I am here but I am confident in the
US and its allies in its decision to do
this to take out those chemical weapons
facilities and I'd be happy to argue
that with anyone who takes issue with
our decision the only ones who are going
to take issue with our decision to do
this to stop Bashar al-assad would
include Syria Russia and Iran I don't
see anyone else coming out in criticism
of these actions has there been a shift
in in policy on Syria now what would
prompt an intervention given Nikki
Haley's comments that the u.s. is locked
and loaded on this issue is it now the
case that every time you're confident
Bashar al Assad uses chlorine on his own
people you will have to use military
force well first I tell you what we
would like to see Bashar al Assad do and
that is declare all of his chemical
weapons declare and get rid of the
chemical weapons that they possess and
Russia can help them Russia was a
signatory and and agreed to help Syria
get rid of its chemical weapons Russia
failed to do so
so that is the first thing that they can
do the United States and her allies
reserves the right to go after Bashar al
Assad if he continues these kinds of
irresponsible and horrific actions I'm
not going to get ahead of the President
or what our allies may decide in the
future but we've made it loud and clear
to Bashar al Assad this has to stop now
has the United States given up on the
United
and security council as a useful forum
for getting legally binding consensus on
issues like Syria no absolutely not
ambassador Haley ambassador nikki Haley
our US ambassador to the United States
is advocating for this each and every
day we had tried all the diplomatic
options over the past year unfortunately
those diplomatic options were blocked by
Russia
so those diplomatic options failed that
is just how the United Nations in the
Security Council happens to work they
have the ability to veto so we've seen
Russia continue to do that we've seen
Bashar al Assad continue to attack and
kill his own people the United States
Britain and France responsible allies
showing Bashar al Assad that he has to
stop we will defend the rights of his
people even when he won't do it himself
have enough